many experts believe that the
coronavirus first emerged in a so-called
wet market in China where exotic
wildlife is often butchered and sold
those markets were closed as part of the
general lockdown but with the pandemic
easing in China they're returning to
life and that reportedly includes the
market in Wuhan linked to the first
reported infections new york times
science and environmental reporter jim
robbins is the author of the article
destroying nature unleashes infectious
diseases it theorizes that most
epidemics including aids Ebola and SARS
are the result of man's interactions
with the natural world you've been
writing about the ecology of disease for
the past five years what's different
about this Anthropocene which means
humans are broadening their footprint of
a natural world and the more we kind of
invade these these natural places the
more we open up to two diseases that
come from animals zoo and notic diseases
is a technical term and we don't have an
immune system in a lot of cases that can
can deal with these disease is a disease
that transfers from from one species to
another right it jumps the species
barrier from animals into humans
bats are believed to may have been the
source for the corona virus so what
happens is these bats are out there
living in a cave somewhere people go in
they chop down the trees the bats leave
because there's people there and then
maybe they drop a piece of half-eaten
fruit into a animal pen and or people
kill them and eat them and the gases
under that human that human goes out and
infects his family his village and from
there just like we're seeing here with
the corona virus your analogy with Lyme
disease was really penetrating for me
when you when you eradicate certain
predators that you in fact are
contributing to
disease spreading throughout you know a
core population people came in and built
roads and homes not knowing that that
they were thinking about the fact that
they were forcing predators out of these
is forests around cities and so this one
particular species called the
white-footed Mouse is a reservoir for
Lyme disease and so it harbors this
disease and it spreads it around now if
we get predators like foxes badgers and
things like that that are gone they
would keep these numbers in check and
Lyme disease wouldn't be the problem
that we need to understand the basics of
how these ecosystems work and try and
restore their function somewhat so we
can protect ourselves against diseases
like Lyme disease or virus have we seen
anything like kovat 19 in our past jump
the species barrier but a couple of
factors come into play here there's
people more people than there ever have
been but the second thing is this
international travel that globally is
taking off so the travel international
transport of goods and people is really
contributing to this as well ten
thousand people a day in this country
retire and they want to travel because
industry is shut down we have clear
skies that animals are starting to
repopulate certain areas I mean is
Mother Nature is Mother Nature resetting
here knows what Mother Nature's intent
is we're not fooling mother nature now
were we're defying mother nature we're
defying these known rules you can only
defy the rules for so long before
there's it's payback time the question
is about whether the natural systems are
going to survive and right now it's
dicey
I'm worried I've covered these issues
for 40 years I just did a story on heat
stress and animals it's taking a toll
someone liking the disappearance of
species to rivets popping on an airplane
that's flying and how many rivets can
you lose on that airplane before things
start to really go to hell so that's my
concern what are some of the large-scale
changes that need to take place
ecological literacy should be taught in
every school because these ecosystems
sustain us as a species even if we don't
realize it what would an ecologically
literate globe look like well I think
that this these principles the ecology
of disease the importance of predators
the importance of protected areas I
think that would all be fundamental one
on one for us clean our water forests
clean our air forests protect us from
disease I think it needs to be taught to
everyone everywhere and based on science
it's the only way to kind of keep us
from tearing apart the world did folks
like you see this coming very definitely
it's for a long time my story and so yes
this is this has been known to be coming
it's just it's they've been waving their
hands people aren't paying attention and
eye-opening perspective there and Jim
said another very relevant example of
this is the wildfires in the past year
or so they are getting larger and larger
and we mess with what he called the
natural fire system we put out a lot of
fires and built homes or fires need to
burn so these fires are getting worse
and worse because there's so much fuel
on the ground Dana yeah Michelle I think
his airplane analogy was so well said
certainly and made sense for so many of
us